DAVID SUMPTER:
Thank you very much.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
So, as Paul said, I work in a
collective behavior research
group, and we're
interested in all forms
of collective behavior--
how individuals
interact with each other
to produce patterns.
So a lot of our research
is about animal groups.
It's about fish
and ants and birds.
But we're also
interested in humans
who have interesting
collective behavior too.
And even things down
at the cellular level,
how cells interact to
produce different patterns.
And what I really like about
coming here and speaking
at Google is that a few years
ago I got really inspired
by your 20% idea, that
you should do something
else with your research
time other than the stuff
that you're doing.
And, of course,
I mean, I already
look at like animal groups
and so that's a load of fun.
But I thought what could we do?
And so in our research group
we started to try and do
a bit of this 20% thing.
We had a fun Friday,
we called it,
where we tried to do some
other type of research.
And connected to all of that,
I came up with the idea,
wouldn't it be fun
to try and apply
how I look at collective
behavior of animals
to looking at collective
behavior in football?
And that's really where
the origin of the idea
of soccermatics came from.
To give you an idea of the
sorts of things I study,
here are three videos.
At the bottom, this
is some clapping
undergraduate students.
We did a study on how
applause starts and stops
after people have
listened to a talk,
a bit like this type of talk.
On the top is the
formation of ant trails.
It's a bit faint
there, but what's shown
is-- in the little
pinkish color-- is
where the ants have
been and where they're
leaving pheromone trails.
Ants communicate with chemicals
and they build up trails
between their nests and food.
And at the top right there,
that is tracks of fish movement.
So that's a small
group of eight fish,
how they're moving around.
And we can work out how they
interact with each other.
So that's really the everyday
type of research we do.
I'm going to go into a
little bit of more details
of these things later on.
But that's to give you
an idea of the types
of collective behavior
that we study.
So coming to soccermatics.
So soccermatics has a lot of
chapters about different ideas
from biology where we
can apply it to football.
And one of the first
ones I came up with
was slime molds from Barcelona.
So the title of
the chapter is How
Slime Molds Built Barcelona.
First I should introduce
you to the slime molds.
Some of you might have
seen slime molds before.
Here is a slime mold.
And what we can see here, this
is a particular experiment
done by Toshi Nakagaki
and his colleagues.
And the slime mold is the
yellow thing in the middle.
On the white things
are oat flakes
that he's left lying out.
He's actually left
them lying out
in the shape of Tokyo suburbs.
So this is the airport in Tokyo,
this is the center of Tokyo,
this is Yokohama down here,
and all of the suburbs of Tokyo
have been left
out as cornflakes.
And what the slime mold does is
it spreads out and connects up
all of these different suburbs.
And it does so in a
very nice, optimal way.
It makes these nice
triangulation patterns
where it can transport all
the nutrients backwards
and forwards between
the center of it
and all of these
different areas.
So slime molds are singular
cellular organisms yet
they can solve these quite
difficult transportation
problems.
The nice thing that
Toshi and his colleagues
did is that they
said, well, can we
compare how the humans
solve this problem
and how the slime
molds solved it?
And it turns out that
the slime molds came up
with pretty much a smart
solution to the Tokyo network
problem as the humans did.
And so they were able
to solve it and produce
these minimal spanning trees or
these connecting networks that
were somehow very close to
what the humans managed to do.
They also tested this--
I like this story
because they also
tested this for Germany
and it was the same result.
It was very efficient.
And France, they
connected up the network.
Then they looked at
the British Rail system
and how the slime mold
compared to the humans
and it came up with a
much better solution.
The slime mold was much better
than the British Rail solution.
OK.
So how do slime molds
connect to Barcelona, right?
Well, let's start by
looking at a goal.
This is one of the greatest
football teams of all time.
This is the Barcelona
team of 2010-2011,
which won the Champions League.
And this, of course,
is Lionel Messi.
One pass, two pass,
and into goal.
It's just an amazing run
where he basically goes
past eight players and gets the
ball into the back of the net.
It's just wonderful to watch.
But what I wanted
to do is, well,
think about what's
actually going on there.
I mean, when you're
looking at this,
you're probably looking
mostly at Messi.
But there's a very
interesting thing
if we look at some
of the other players.
So now I've taken-- I've
tracked the positions of all
of the players and I've put them
down onto the football pitch.
And we can see that
Messi is over there
and Xavi is over here.
And then we have Iniesta here.
And what I've done is
made a triangulation,
very similar to what happens
with the slime molds,
connecting all of these players.
And you see this really lovely
triangulation between Xavi here
and Iniesta and you have
the opposing players
are sort of caught
in the middle.
And Xavi is perfectly placed
between these one, two, three,
four, five other players.
He's right in the
middle of them.
And by moving into the
middle at the same time
he produces a triangle
where he can then
take the ball from Messi and
pass it on to the next player.
So we can actually break this
down as a Voronoi diagram
and see that the
opposing players are
stuck on the line
between Xavi and Messi,
which makes it very easy
for him to do the pass.
Then what does Messi do next?
Well, this is Pedro.
Just now he's standing
marked by another player.
But one second later, when
Messi has moved forward,
you see suddenly that Pedro is
standing in the middle of one,
two, three, four.
It's just a subtle movement,
just one meter away,
produces the same
triangular effect again.
And this is what Barcelona do
time after time after time.
They create space and
through creating space,
they create these triangles
which they can pass.
Once Pedro has done that,
the ball goes to Pedro.
This is just in a
one-meter space.
And Messi is through.
And so when we watch it
again, we see pass one.
Pass two, Pedro
moved into space.
And the goal goes in.
So that was the whole
structure between
that particular Barcelona team.
Now I've been
working with data--
I've been writing articles
for "FourFourTwo" magazine
and working with data from Opta.
And now we can actually
look at the whole passing
network throughout the match.
So this is Barcelona
versus Arsenal.
This is now
modern-day Barcelona.
This was the season match
where they knocked Arsenal out
of the Champions League.
And again we can see
very nice selection
of triangles between Messi
on this side and Dani Alves
and Rakitic.
And then up at the top, we
have Neymar, Iniesta, and Alba.
And what I love about
the Barcelona network,
it just has this sort
of perfect symmetry.
You basically have
Messi and two players,
you have Neymar and
two players, you
have Busquets which
you can go back to,
and then you have Suarez
at the tip of it all.
And there's a sort of
symmetry down the middle.
And by looking at the passes
that all of the players made,
you can identify what are the
key components of Barcelona.
What makes them such
a successful team?
And I've been doing--
I got really into this.
When I got hold
of this Opta data,
it was so much fun to make
all of these different passing
networks.
This is a different type of
passing network I've made.
This is from earlier in
the season, Manchester City
versus Leicester.
And this is a
passing network which
shows the average pass position
between different players.
So up here is the average
place that Sterling
passed to Kolarov.
This is the average place
Kolarov passed off to Sterling.
And then we can build up a
convex hull which connects
all of these passing points.
And you get an idea of
where is the territory
for these different places.
And it's interesting to see
that Sterling placed basically
across the two wings,
and this is something
that Manchester City do.
So you can get a
very nice idea, which
goes above the normal
formations of a football match,
of how a team works together.
So that's the basic network
connection, and the starting
with the slime mold.
The next thing that
I wanted to look at
was the flow of the game.
So there's a chapter in the
book called Check My Flow.
And the starting point
for this was an experiment
done by Messi Moussaid.
He did a very simple experiment,
but it's a very nice and useful
experiment.
He placed-- he did it in France.
And he placed-- had
had two students.
So one of them stood here
and the other student
was walking towards
the stationary student.
And what this vector
field shows you,
what all the arrows
show you, is the effect
that a stationary student
has on a moving student.
And so he's taken away-- they've
always got forward motion,
but you can see they've slowed
down when they're in this area.
And if they're off to the
left, they go off to the left,
and if they're off to the
right, they go off to the right.
And he actually found that there
was a small, small bias-- maybe
a sort of 60-40 bias--
that these arrows are just
a bit stronger off to the right.
So there's a sort
of bigger tendency
to go off to the right.
And this means when you have
two walking students who
meet each other,
they end up passing
each other on the right.
And so this is a
nice example of how
you can model individual
interactions in humans
and work out what's going on.
So what I wanted to
do was use this type
of vector field, this type
of flow field approach,
in order to understand what's
going on in a football match.
This is another one of
my very favorite players.
Up here is Andrea Pirlo.
He's just got the ball
here and he puts it across.
So watch what Pirlo does now.
He sort of strolls around.
He has this beautiful style
of just he doesn't even
look like he can run properly.
He kind of moves
there over there,
he sort of strolls around
with the ball a little bit
like this.
Oh, I've fallen over.
Yeah, I'm not really
going to do anything here.
I'll just stand here for a bit.
And then pang!
He just places this
beautiful pass out
to a free player, one more pass,
and then the ball is suddenly
in the middle and it's a goal.
This was the semifinal
of the Euro 2012.
And that's really Pirlo's
mode of operation.
He was one of the key
players in that game.
Time and time again, he was
in the middle of the field
standing there and
then putting out
these passes in
different directions.
And what I can do is I can
produce the same type of flow
field for Pirlo.
And I like to call him the eye
of the storm, because basically
he has this operation area.
This is a heat map of where
he's most often passing from.
And if he's on the
right-hand side,
he tends to pass out to the
left, which he did in the video
we saw.
If he's on the left, he
passes out to the right.
And that's his operation.
He's really tightly constrained
to a particular point
and making these passes
out in different direction.
This is the average data-- well,
I've fitted a model to this,
but it's the average
data taken over a match.
And then you can compare
to other players.
So Schweinsteiger
plays for Germany.
And he would actually say
that he-- in that match,
he played the same
midfield position as Pirlo,
but he has a completely
different vector
field or flow field.
He is moving everywhere
around the pitch.
He has these long passes in this
direction and some going out
that direction, and he
moves much more around.
So I think if Pirlo is
the eye of the storm,
then Schweinsteiger
is a tornado that
just engulfs the whole pitch.
And what I like about this is
it's sort of like an analogy
here, or there's a
sort of prediction.
It's like a weather
forecast prediction.
If we look at that,
well, now we've
got a forecast of
how Schweinsteiger
is going to play.
And this is exactly how he
played in the World Cup final.
He was everywhere in the World
Cup final two years later.
And I don't think
he single-handedly
won the World Cup
final, but he was
one of the absolute key
players in doing it.
So you sort of have
a weather forecast
which predicts how a player
will play in future matches.
And what's been nice to do
now looking at this Opta data
is to do this for players.
So this is Riyad
Mahrez, who's been
one of the successful players
for Leicester this season.
He plays out on
the right midfield.
And you can see exactly
where Mahrez is.
You know this is where he's
going to be, that black thing,
and you can also see where
he's passing the ball.
This shows why
it's so effective.
The ball keeps flowing
in, in this direction.
This is where Vardy
is, for example.
All of his passes
are creating chances
going in that direction.
And you can use this technique
to compare different players.
Because we're in London,
I mean-- actually
because we're in London, you're
probably all Manchester United
fans.
But I thought I'd show you
some of the leading attacking
midfielders for the London team.
So Eden Hazard for Chelsea up
there, Mesut Ozil for Arsenal,
Christian Eriksen for Spurs,
and Dimitri Payet for West Ham.
And ostensibly
these players play
in round about
the same position,
but they have very
different attacking arrows.
Eden Hazard has had
a really bad season,
and you can sort of see why.
If you compare to Ozil
on the right here,
Ozil's passes are always moving
forward in this direction
while Eden Hazard is passing
more into the middle.
So he's not making
the ball move forward.
Christian Eriksen is
doing a pretty good job
of making the ball move forward.
And Payet is doing
very long passes.
These are crosses into the box.
And so he's moving the
ball in a good direction.
So you can get an idea
of the style of play
of the different players
and whether they're
effective in this play.
OK.
So up to now I've been
looking at on-the-ball data.
I've been looking at when the
player has the ball, where
is the player moving
to the ball to.
But there's more and more
technology available now
to actually track all of the
movement of all of the players.
This data is collected
by individuals,
by people watching the match
and saying who's got the ball
and tracking the
positions on the pitch.
But it is actually possible
to automate it, automatically
track all of the
positions of the players.
This is the kind of
interesting problem
that I'm sure you guys are
interested in at Google.
And so I have a chapter on the
World in Motion, I call it,
and that's where I really
like to think about what we've
done in our own fish research.
So-- OK.
So this is a film from a BBC
documentary showing really
some of the most beautiful
patterns that fish
create, and I
thought I'd give you
an idea about how
they work in the wild
before we move into the lab.
So these are sort of balls
of mackerel and other fish
you see if you go diving, and
they create these massive balls
of movement.
And the point is that
no individual fish
has any idea of the pattern
that it's creating as a whole.
They're just moving
around, following
their local
neighbors, yet they're
producing these incredibly
intricate and complicated
patterns.
One of the big
steps forward when
we wanted to model these
things mathematically
was just the simple idea
of looking at what we call
self-propelled particle models.
The idea is that you
have this particle here,
and it just follows
the direction
of the other
particles around it.
So if I allow this--
this red particle
would just follow the
direction of the black particle
and it just starts to
move forward in this.
And then I can take and
simulate the whole thing.
So now I'm just
running this on--
so if they go off one boundary,
they come back on to the other.
And you can see
our red focal fish.
But what is really cool here
is you've just got this local
interaction that's shown by the
grey area and quite quickly you
get a sort of something that
doesn't look so different from
a fish school.
You have movement in
the same direction,
you have groups moving around,
and it has that same kind
of complex motion.
So just from a few--
a very simple rule
of following your neighbors, you
can create a fish school that
moves in the same direction.
And when we do this in the
lab, we study exactly this.
We, as I showed the
film before, we're
tracking the
individual fish and we
want to work out what
are the rules of motion
that these fish are following.
Another example is here.
This is an escape experiment.
We frighten the fish
and we can see--
we can watch a wave of
escape going through them.
We can't do these
massive experiments
like they do in the
wild, but we can
get a nice idea of how
the fish are interacting.
And for quite a few
years now, we've
been doing what we call
rules of motion experiments.
We look at how fish--
this focal fish--
interacts with its neighbors.
This is an example of
how a fish accelerates
depending on the position
of its neighbors.
This is a similar thing
done with pigeons.
How does a pigeon
change direction
as a function of the
position of its neighbors?
And we can get a
really good idea
of how these fish and how
these pigeons interact
with each other.
And recently to try and prove
how good we were at this,
we did what we call
the fish Turing test.
The job for you now is
to spot the real fish
and the non-real fish as they
swim around in this arena.
And actually I think-- I have
to confess that I have forgotten
the answer to which is the
real fish and which is the--
And so we actually-- we did an
experiment and the real fish
experts could tell
slightly better than random
between simulated
fish and real fish.
But we found that
members of the public
were unable to distinguish
real fish and simulated fish.
So we're pretty close
to solve-- yeah.
There's always more
interesting problems with fish,
but there's-- we're pretty
close to having a nice solution
of how fish interact
with each other.
But that gives the nice thing
of having a new challenge
and that's football.
So this is a
eight-against-eight match.
The pitch is a bit
complicated here
because they're playing
on half a pitch.
So they've got the goal
here and the goal there.
And so these pitch
markings are just
because they're playing
a part of the pitch.
They're playing
from left to right.
And if you look
to the green team,
that shows the correlations
between the players,
how closely they're
moving together.
When they're green
they correlated well.
And suddenly when the
yellow team get the ball,
they switch from being highly
correlated to blue, which is
what happens when you attack.
Then you become unsynchronized.
They've lost the
ball again and then
they become green, which means
that they're highly correlated.
And you can actually look to see
which player is following which
in these systems.
That's the pointiness
of the arrows.
And what we've
identified there is
defense is a
synchronized movement,
and attack is basically
about making more
random, unexpected movements.
This is kind of
preliminary work.
This is a particular test
data set that we have.
And this is really
the stuff that
will be being done over
the next five or 10
years is trying to
understand this type of data
and to see if you can understand
the basics of what happens
in a football
match and if we can
think about how to improve it.
We have a few ideas about this.
One experiment we've
done on the fish
is we're interested in this
idea of collective vision.
What the color here shows
is what-- the white areas is
things that all of
the fish can see,
the red areas are things that
only one or two of the fish
can see areas of this thing.
So we can get an idea about
what the fish group can see.
And that's exactly what
we are interested in doing
in a football match.
This is another situation from
Barcelona and over on this side
I've tried to plot where are the
possible passes that Busquets
can make over to Messi.
And the red areas show
things which are blocked
and the green areas
show possible passes.
And you can take-- this was a
student of mine, [INAUDIBLE]
who did this work.
And what you can do is you can
take different match situations
and you can say--
this is James Milner
in a match for Liverpool.
And he basically has
two passing options.
He has, one, to try and get the
ball through to Sturridge there
which is a much narrower chance,
or he can play the ball out
to the wing.
And so you can evaluate these
different match situations
and say when should you decide
to make these certain things.
It's much more valuable
to make this type of pass
because it's much
more dangerous,
but what's the
probability of success.
And you can show that to
the players after the match
and say, well, you
decided to do that here.
Maybe you should make a
different decision last time
based on statistics.
And that's where
I think you can--
this is where you have these
beautifully big data sets which
you can kind of
learn on and decide,
make good decision
rules for football.
Good.
So that's the collective motion.
The last thing I'm going to
just touch on for five minutes
is what I call the Tactical Map.
So this uses some of the
ideas we've looked at so far
and some extra things.
And this one is not
in the book because I
wrote the book before the whole
Leicester City phenomenon.
But I decided
quite early on that
I had to look at this
Leicester City thing
and work out what was going on.
And this is a nice picture
of the defensive zones
that Leicester City create.
So they basically have two areas
where they defend the ball.
These shapes are the typical
areas where Leicester City
players recover the ball.
They of course have a back
four, a very traditional
back four-- Fuchs, Huth,
Morgan, and Simpson
playing in the back four.
But he's a bit faint
in the picture,
but Kante has been one
of their star players.
He defends in front of the
back four, picking up the ball
and then shooting
it up to either
to Mahrez or Vardy or
Albrighton, who are then
very effective in striking.
But you see this
territory at the back,
and what Leicester have also
been extremely good in doing
is that they own this territory
further up at the front
and they're often getting the
ball back up here, which allows
them to do very fast attacks.
Or if the ball
comes up from Kante,
maybe Vardy doesn't
get it first time
but he recovers it
very quickly and then
he can continue
to attack on goal.
So you can see where the
defensive territories are.
And I did a study
back in February
looking at what is it
that makes Leicester
different from the other teams.
And it turned out that if
you break the pitch into x-y
coordinates and you look
each pass, how far does it
travel across the pitch
and how far does it
travel up the pitch during
the time that they're passing.
And this is across the pitch
and this is up the pitch.
Leicester City are off
the charts with passes
directly up the pitch.
There are other teams which
we call long-ball teams
like West Ham United, Crystal
Palace, and Southampton.
They're doing
crosses into the box.
But Leicester are playing
directly up the pitch.
Before Leicester
City, this was what
was considered to
be good quality
football that Arsenal,
Manchester City, Liverpool
are trying to do it.
Chelsea.
Manchester United, what they're
doing is they've got the ball,
they're passing very short
passes to one another.
They think that they've
got the best players
and so they try and control
with a lot of possession
and a lot of fast
passing to each other.
And they did that this season.
In previous seasons, it's been
these teams that have won.
But this season by stepping
exactly into this area,
Leicester City seem to
be much more effective.
One last thing I didn't
say about this plot
is that the size of the circle
is the number of chances
generated by the teams.
So Arsenal had an
incredible number of chances
but unfortunately they
didn't have the strikers
to score any of the goals.
And Leicester City
had less chances
but they were very effective
in converting them.
Then lastly, this is now a
season network of-- Leicester
were very nice because they have
pretty much the same players
on the pitch
throughout the season
and so you can get a good
idea of who was passing who.
So the circle here
is how many shots
from the danger zone
in front of goal
were done by a
particular player.
So Vardy is this
massive circle here,
but even Huth is a
pretty big circle.
Doesn't mean he shot from there.
He shot closer in.
But this is the typical
position that they pass from.
And you can get an idea of how
Leicester move the ball around.
Kante is the central point
that's connecting up everybody.
So, again, you've
got some sort of tool
for analyzing performance.
I've been talking to a few
different football clubs
and people who are
doing this type of data
and what's
increasingly being done
is that there's
this integration.
There will be an
opposition analyst who
look at the passing,
this type of data,
then they'll try and compare
it to their own knowledge.
And then this should go
into-- player has an iPad
and is looking at
the data and trying
to improve their own play for
these training sessions which
can be based on preparing
for particular tactics
that the team you're meeting
is going to play against.
And then the manager
is, of course,
doing their traditional
presentation of the results.
So I think this type
of data is going
to be more and more integrated
into how football clubs work.
Good.
That was the main
things I wanted to say,
and so I'll just
finish with-- that's
three chapters of the book.
So I'll just finish
with a little plug
for some of the other things.
Some of the other
chapters in the book.
So I live in Sweden and
there Zlatan Ibrahimovic
is the big hero so I had
to do an analysis of Zlatan
Ibrahimovic.
And I analyzed the trajectory
of his overhead lob goal
kick against England from
a couple of years ago.
So that was a lot of
fun to do that analysis.
Then I have a little bit on
game theory and strategy.
My point there is
that by-- like birds
are able to evolve to
have particular strategies
and managers are also
able to evolve and have
optimal strategies, possibly
not by being the smartest people
but just by watching each other
and adopting their strategies.
And I talk about why you should
have three points for a win,
because it makes more
attacking football.
You'll Never Walk Alone
is about crowd movement.
And I look at applause and
how applause is infectious,
a bit like the
clapping study we did.
But also thinking
about how songs
start in a football ground.
You have this
really rapid spread
of particular songs
between people
and it's really to do
with exponential growth
and infection.
Then I have a bit on
collective wisdom.
So how betting provides some
form of collective wisdom.
There was this lovely book,
"This Wisdom of Crowds,"
and so I look a
bit deeper at some
of the assumptions in "This
Wisdom of Crowds" in that.
And then I end the book
by putting my money
where my mouth is
and try and beat
the betting market
using some of the things
that I've learned
about football.
And I did actually manage to
make a little bit of money.
You can read about
it in the book.
But it turned out that,
yeah, there was two things.
It turned out that I had-- it
was a very boring strategy that
made me lots of money.
It was just to bet on draws.
So that wasn't so much fun.
And also I challenged my
wife, who is sitting here,
to the betting
thing, and she claims
that she had a deep and
sophisticated system.
I'm not too convinced
of that, but in the end
she did actually win
more money than me.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're still looking into
the science behind that.
I'm not sure what it is.
But, anyway, so there's
a bit on betting.
And actually at the
end of it, I conclude
that instead of becoming
a professional gambler,
you should probably come and
work for Google or something
like that where you actually
get a regular salary
and can use the same
types of skills.
And that's it.
Yeah, I think you've
all-- lots of you
have got copies of the book.
And, yeah, it was out yesterday.
So thank you very much.
So now we'll open the
floor to questions.
Got one already.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very
much for the talk.
How many clubs have
offered you a job?
DAVID SUMPTER: Oh, none of them.
No.
It's not-- I mean,
I've talked to clubs.
It's very interesting
about that actually
because mainly I've
met some analysts
and they do complain
a little bit
about trying to get that
cycle that I described right.
That it really isn't like that.
The lifetime of a
manager just now is-- you
know, it's a year or something.
So it's very difficult
to get that sort
of thing going in a club.
Just now they use a lot of
stuff for scouting and so on.
But, yeah, the answer to
your question is none as yet.
I'm open to offers.
AUDIENCE: Have you looked--
you did a lot of this
produce as a result like
this, and this looks similar.
And but have you
actually investigated
how predictive it is?
So where a scientific
experiment would be done,
do it on some
training data and then
see if it predicts the future?
DAVID SUMPTER: Yeah.
That's a really-- I mean,
in the betting thing I did.
I used those types of predictive
approaches to fit the data.
But actually it's
quite interesting
because I know
that you guys here,
or some of you
guys who'll be here
are very into this sort of
machine learning type of stuff.
And we do a lot of that
machine learning type of stuff
as well in developing
the models of the fish
and then you do
predictive things.
But it tends to be in science
that you get more understanding
from sort of messing around
with different types of models
trying to see which
reproduce the behavior,
trying to work out if it's
consistent at an individual
level and a collective level.
And it isn't always
predictive in that way.
It's more of a trying to
create models to create
some sort of understanding.
And I suppose I'm doing that
in the football as well.
That it's not that I
can take those networks,
put them against each
other and predict
the result of the next match.
That just-- we're
not really there yet.
It's more about understanding
where things are working
and where things are not
working within the club.
AUDIENCE: Hi, David.
Thanks for coming.
Two quick ones.
So the first one is where
do you get the data.
Is it some kind of
public repository?
DAVID SUMPTER: Yeah.
So I've had a-- no,
the data is from Opta,
the on-the-ball data.
And that's a private company.
And they collect in this data.
I've been very lucky to have
a good relationship with them
because I wrote for
"FourFourTwo" magazine.
They have a thing
called Stats Zone.
So you can go in
and see all the data
and I'm sure very
clever people like
you could scrape the data
in about five minutes,
but so it's all there.
But it's owned by
this company Opta.
And but they're very good.
They like to encourage this type
of blog academic type of thing.
So they've shared it
with me and there's
a website called Stats Bomb
where they use this data
just for nonprofit,
analyzing and having fun
playing around with it.
But otherwise, they
sell it to clubs
and they sell it to
the media and so on.
AUDIENCE: And second one.
Was your kind of
mathematical prediction
for the next Champions League--
DAVID SUMPTER: For the next--
for the Champions League final?
AUDIENCE: No, not necessarily
of the outcome, but how the--
DAVID SUMPTER: I
have to-- I'm going
to write an article about
this for "The Mirror"
and I haven't started
looking at it.
But I was very disappointed
because of-- it's much more fun
to do an analysis of
Bayern Munich than it is--
and Barcelona is
one of my favorites.
So I was at least hoping
to have Bayern in the final
before I start my analysis.
So just now I don't
have a prediction
and I'm just trying to get
over the disappointment
of not having the most
mathematically beautiful team
in the final.
AUDIENCE: And
you're saying that.
I'm from Madrid, so I'm--
DAVID SUMPTER: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
Yeah, OK, so-- OK,
well you-- which
side are you on then in this?
AUDIENCE: Real.
DAVID SUMPTER: OK.
They're going to win.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you see
the effect of managers?
So if someone
changes team, can you
see after a few
weeks, a few months,
that the influence they
bring to those players
changes the tactics of
the individual players?
DAVID SUMPTER: Yes.
I did an analysis on Klopp
when he came to Liverpool.
So Liverpool's my
club, and I looked
to see what-- is he doing
this counter pressing thing
more effectively than when
Rodgers was in charge?
And it turned out that
in the first six weeks
he wasn't doing more
counter pressing.
This counter pressing is
where you run, try and get
the ball immediately
back if you've
lost it in the opponent's half.
Leicester are pretty good at it.
And he wasn't doing
this to start with.
But then after about 12 weeks,
he'd actually got that working.
And you could see a
statistically significant
difference between his press
and the pressing under Klopp
and the pressing under Rodgers.
So that-- yeah, that's the sort
of thing that you can analyze.
Because the managers have
such short lifetimes,
they often get sacked for
unfortunate statistical
anomalies really, like they just
lost three matches in a row.
And so that's a big problem.
One thing you do
know is that you
would need to assess these
things for longer times
normally than the
lifetimes of managers.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So it
seems from your graph
like Leicester are playing
quite a different style to sort
of most of the other top teams.
Do you think that that is
them having sort of broken out
of the little
tactical local minimum
and that's why they've
been so successful?
Or more like they've just been
successful in the short term
because they're doing
something different?
Do you think other
teams could copy that?
Or is it just like a
temporary flash in the pan?
DAVID SUMPTER: Yeah.
I mean, that's the big
question, isn't it?
I think there is something
to learn in there, because we
can see there is a statistical
difference between them.
So and what you see in football
is this constant evolution.
So the Barcelona
team of 2010-11,
there were lots of teams
which tried to copy that.
Like, Swansea tried to do this,
and Arsenal to some degree
have tried to play like this.
And now it doesn't work anymore.
You can't attack through the
D because-- I think really
Mourinho is credited with this.
He came up with, well, you just
pack everyone in the middle
and only Messi is going to
get through that and not
even Messi is going to get
through it all the time.
So he came up with a defense
which counteracted that.
When he played
against Barcelona,
he let them go out to the
edges as much as they wanted
because they were
all tiny so they
couldn't cross in to the
players in the middle.
So that's one thing where you
see this tactical evolution.
And Leicester seem to
have evolved a system
that the others weren't
ready to handle.
And the problem with
Arsenal is possibly
they were actually
maximizing something.
They were maximizing-- we
often call this expected goals.
They were maximizing
that shots should
come from a certain area,
and the other teams knew
that they were
maximizing that and then
they started blocking it.
And then Arsenal didn't do well.
But they had no strategy
for dealing with Leicester.
So there's this constant
evolution and feedback.
And, yeah, you will see teams
copying Leicester next season,
but it's not a guarantee
that it will work.
Something else might come along.
AUDIENCE: So you don't think
Leicester will be successful
next season?
That's your official prediction?
DAVID SUMPTER: You're
filming this, aren't you?
I mean, they could very well
be successful next season.
I thought that the
5,000 to 1 odds on them
this season-- not at
the time, but when
I found out afterwards.
I mean, that's ridiculous odds.
That means like 1 in 5,000 years
that they would win the League
and, like, it's only
20, 30 years ago
since, like,
Nottingham Forest were
winning the League and other
teams in Ipswich and so on.
So, no, it's not impossible.
I don't think that
Leicester will win,
but I don't actually
know who will win.
I've done it in
the book, and I do
this study is when
experts predict who's
going to win the
next season, experts
are-- their guesses are worse
than just writing the League
table from the season
before on average.
They always, like, have small
biases where they get it wrong.
So I can tell-- yeah.
So my prediction
for next season is
that Leicester will win
the League, that Spurs
will be second,
because that's the best
prediction we know of making
a whole League season.
AUDIENCE: So did you
also do some sort
of comparative
analysis of Leicester
before they became
quite so successful?
I think they were in
real trouble last season
and then maybe the last eight
or nine games they won a lot of.
Have you sort of done the
graphs and pinpointed the place
where the style changed?
DAVID SUMPTER:
That's a good point.
I haven't done that.
I did last season
vs this season,
and they weren't doing these
longer passes in that way
last season.
So there was a change.
But what I didn't account
for is, as you were saying,
is if there might be a time
point during last season
that they made a transition.
So over the whole
season, they weren't
doing what they did this
season, but possibly at the end
they were.
AUDIENCE: Did you
take a look at how
single player behaves under,
like, different managers?
So let's say, for
example, in the club
versus like national team.
So, like, Vardy is
waiting for long balls
basically and scores a
lot of goals in League.
But perhaps he's not the
best choice for England
because the tactics
are different,
so they can use the strength.
Whereas with Pirlo you
get always the same--
DAVID SUMPTER: Yeah.
It's true.
So I've got--
yeah, one example I
think is nice about that is
this Schweinsteiger thing.
So when he was signed
for-- he wasn't really
allowed to play like
that at Bayern Munich
like he played for
the German team.
And he certainly
wasn't allowed to play
like that at Manchester United.
So I did some heat
maps for Schweinsteiger
at Manchester United and
he had to stay-- this is
your position, Schweinsteiger.
You stay here and pass
the ball over there,
because that's the
structure that van Gaal has.
So you definitely see changes
in where they're allowed to do,
and those tend to
be instructions
that come from the manager.
I think, rather than them
being confined to not being
able to play in the same way.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
will ask one more.
The weather, how much does that
play and effect different teams
or different players?
Did you look at that?
DAVID SUMPTER: That's
a good question.
No, I haven't looked at
that, have to be honest.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Next book.
DAVID SUMPTER: Yes, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Any more questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You know of the
Football Manager game?
DAVID SUMPTER: I know of it.
I started playing it, but
it was so incredibly boring.
Sorry.
I don't know.
I had to, like-- I
started, I thought, ah,
I really have to get into this.
And then it said, you
know, the youth team coach
wants to know this.
It was like running
a real foot-- I mean,
yeah if you played it, it was
like running a football team.
Which is brilliant, but, you
know, I have a full-time job.
I'm trying to write
a football book,
going around, talking
to people like you.
Unfortunately, I
didn't have enough time
to really sit down and play it.
But it looks very realistic.
And I know-- yeah, I
mean to answer-- well,
that wasn't your question, but
one really interesting thing
about "Football Manager"
is that it was bought up
by Prozone or their
scouting system
because they send
people out to collect
in all this information.
So when you look at the
Liverpool under-15s team,
it is the Liverpool
under-15s team.
They've collected them in
and somebody-- some amateurs
have gone and watched the teams.
There's an incredible data
collection network that
is inside "Football Manager."
It's really realistic
at that level.
AUDIENCE: Just picking up
on Rob's question just now.
Have you done any analysis on
home versus away advantages?
DAVID SUMPTER: There is home
versus away advantages still.
It's been decreasing for
the last, like, 10 years,
but there still is.
And there's not actually
a really solid explanation
of why it is.
One of it is pitch size,
for example, if you
train on a certain pitch.
There was this lovely thing
where Real Madrid went
through in the
Champions League-- I
can't remember who they had,
but they were two-nil down.
It was Wolfsburg I think.
They were two-nil
down on aggregate.
And they just made their
pitch 60 centimeters wider
on both sides, which,
when you do the maths,
is a lot wider in square meters.
And then they won three-nil
on the return visit.
So you can make those small
adjustments to your tactics
based on the pitch you play in.
And, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you coach your
son's football team, I believe.
Has any of your research made
it into the tactics used there?
DAVID SUMPTER: Yeah.
It has to some degree.
I mean, we're a bunch of
dads who do the coaching,
and so I'm not the only one.
And they kind of-- but I do the
passing network stuff, and any
of you who coach kids
teams or anything,
you just need a piece of
paper with a formation
of the team written
on it and you can just
draw a line between
all the players
who are passing each other.
And you can immediately-- and
then some things with shots
and so on.
This is statistics I
collect during the matches
and then I show it to them.
I mean, OK, they're only 9 or
10, but they really love it.
And we do things like instead
of who scored the most goals,
it's like which pair of players
made the most successful passes
between the two of them.
And it's a great
way of encouraging
them to do teamwork.
And, I don't know.
I don't like to boast,
but we're actually
a very successful team.
And we won the district
championships last year.
So and that's-- I don't think
that's down to my soccermatical
skills, but it's a lot of
fun to try and put that stuff
into the game.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks.
So tournaments
like the FA Cup are
known for being very surprising
and having a lot of shocks.
How much of that do you think
is because premiership teams
are playing lower
league teams who
have like incompatible networks
that they don't see often.
Or how much of it is just
due to some kind of magic
that you'll never be able
to statistically predict?
DAVID SUMPTER: Yeah.
Some of it is going to be
down to that sort of thing.
But the thing you have
to start off remembering
is that 2/3 of
everything that happens
in a football match is
random in the outcome and 1/3
is down to skill.
And you can think
of it like this.
So you have three goals
in the football match.
One of them goes to the best
team and then two of them
are spread randomly
between the two teams.
And it's maybe it's
a bit more than one
maybe in an FA Cup
match, but there's always
that sort of random
chance that the teams are
going to go through.
So you're always going to have
one of those dream stories,
you know, the giant
killers or whatever.
And probably the
first thing to look at
is the random
explanation before you
start to look at any tactical
genius of these division
two trainers who have got
them up to that level.
But that's why you
want to have cups
and you don't just
want to have leagues.
But apart from this
season, leagues
have been extremely
predictable and cups always
throw up a bit
more of excitement
due to the randomness.
AUDIENCE: Right.
There is a chapter
on Ibrahimovic,
and did you find
an answer why he's
so successful in
national leagues
and doesn't win anything in the
European level, even the club?
DAVID SUMPTER: That's
a good question.
No, I don't know
the answer to why.
I mean, it might just be--
it's harder in the cups.
I mean, it's the same with,
like, Pep Guardiola has
got to the semifinal
of-- yeah, it's
this thing about Bayern
Munich, that he's
got to the semifinal
three times now
and hasn't won the
Champions League.
There is that
random factor which
just means that you
don't always go through.
So, yeah, Zlatan has gone
to the quarterfinals eight
times or something and
then not gone through.
So I don't know.
I wouldn't read
too much into that.
Well, I'm not a Swede but
I'm still proud of Zlatan,
so I'm not going to say
anything bad about him.
I would be very scared in case I
might meet him one day as well.
AUDIENCE: I guess this
is kind of related
to your [INAUDIBLE] statistics
about your child's team.
But you showed an
eight-on-eight passing network
kind of real time.
How was that data collected
and could you kind of
do that for your own team?
Is that professionally done?
DAVID SUMPTER: Yeah.
So that was professionally done.
That was like
17-year-olds playing
and they were basically
collecting that data in order
to test the system.
And they put two or
three local GPSs on them
that can collect data very
locally and very accurately
on their feet and on
their body as well.
And so that technology exists.
It's not yet used in
the Premier League.
It was used in the Women's
World Cup, for example.
They all had a very
accurate GPS on them.
And, yeah, so I did actually
try it with my son's team,
I have to admit.
We got some GPSs and
put them onto them
and measured their movements.
But they weren't
accurate enough.
So if Google are interested
in funding a research project
on looking at player
movements, then I
have some very
willing volunteers
who'd like to be involved.
SPEAKER 1: A 20% project
for someone perhaps.
DAVID SUMPTER: Exactly.
SPEAKER 1: Please join me
and Peter in thanking David
very much.